Oh clear which way oh you say something  I said I want to call my eyes out but  unfortunately you weren't doing it good  cuz I already saw the awfulness will you  focus on focus this pretty place is  about to get are gonna fight real quick  buy a bunch of freakin elves do you know  you know I saw all these people who died  so this is a little bit difficult for me  okay so why won't you reach down deep  inside and try and find a small humanity  dis tomato page  give me the things you may think  anything to come here you're  embarrassing all right which way you  don't know you used to freaking live  here for 1500 years not forever  no ethic yeah maybe we are dead we are  so so dead this is the fight of our  lives we are getting the whole team  right oh it's a regular sized man hey  guys  is that everyone you wanted more  are you crying this is my destiny  Avengers Assemble  [Applause]  [Music]  no no give me that you have the little  one  [Music]